ROMAN NURIK: All right.
Hello, everyone.
Welcome to Android
Design in Action.
This week's episode is
unlike the other
episodes that you've seen.
This week we're going
to have a hangout,
Google+ Hangout on air.
Oh, right, that's probably
a good idea.
We're going to have a Google+
Hangout on air to discuss
design, specifically this show
or other top tips or anything
that folks may have.
I'm, as always, your
host, Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: Hey, guys,
Adam Koch.
ROMAN NURIK: And Nick Butcher
unfortunately
couldn't join today.
I think he's out sick.
We've invited him to the Hangout
just in case he wants
to join, but he'll probably
stay home and
rest up for next week.
So with that, let's
get started.
We're going to structure the
format of this Hangout not
like a regular Hangout where
we just talk about stuff.
We're going to go into a few
slides in the very beginning.
We want to talk briefly about
the Nexus 4 and the Nexus 10
very, very briefly.
And then at the end, we'll have
a few slides, as well.
But for most of this episode,
we'll be talking to the folks
that have joined to see what
thoughts they may have.
So let's jump into the slides.
So Android Design in Action.
Let's see if I can navigate
this thing.
There we go.
So the Nexus 4 and Nexus 10.
As many of you know these
are the newest
devices coming from Google.
These are the newest
devices in the
Nexus family of products.
The Nexus 4 is a handset.
It's 4.7 inches diagonally.
You can see all the
screen specs here.
The Nexus 10 is a 10-inch
device, so it's a new
reference device, if you will,
for a 10-inch size, kind of
replacing the Motorola Zoom,
in our opinion, for pure
Android experiences.
The important thing to note is
that this is I guess the first
time, Adam, that we've
had such a
high-density tablet display.
Before, almost all tablet
displays, 10-inch tablet
displays, have been MDPI.
ADAM KOCH: I don't think any
of them have been anything
other than MDPI.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, yeah.
So they've all been roughly, I
guess, 1, 280 by 800 pixels,
so this doubles that.
So you now have a crazy number
of pixels on the screen.
The good thing is that the dip
resolution hasn't changed, so
your existing layouts
will just work.
The difference, though, is that
the assets that will be
used in those layouts, you know
if you have buttons and
things like that, they'll
be twice the density, so
basically 320 DPI assets.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, any assets
I guess shared
from your phone UI--
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, any assets
shared from your phone UI,
obviously the tablet UI on Nexus
10 will just pick those
up immediately.
But if you have any assets that
are specific to tablet
layouts, you will need to
update to include XHDPI.
Also for Nexus 4, it's worth
mentioning that the width is
slightly larger than
Galaxy Nexus.
It's 1,280 by 768 as opposed
to 1,280 by 720.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, and that maps
to about 24 extra dips--
horizontal dips of
resolution--
for the Nexus 4 as compared to
the Galaxy Nexus or other
devices like that.
So that's the new devices.
I mean, there's lots and lots of
other stuff to talk about,
but you guys probably know all
these things from all the
different press that's
been out there.
But these are some of the
details that are probably
important to designers
in thinking
about these new devices.
And then just to recap.
We now have the Nexus 4, the
Nexus 7 and the Nexus 10.
And here are, again,
their rough screen
specs, if you will.
The other thing we should
point out is
that launcher icons--
as many of you know, when
designing for MDPI tablets, I
guess the older density or the
earlier density for tablets,
you'll also want to provide
an HDPI launcher icon.
Because what the launcher does--
and the launcher is
that home screen, as
many of you know.
What the launcher does is when
it displays an icon for an
app, it chooses the one bucket
larger icon because it wants a
physically larger icon.
So instead of showing a
48-by-48 dip icon in a
launcher, it actually
chooses to show
a larger icon launcher.
So to get an icon of that high
resolution, it basically uses
a shortcut.
It basically looks at the
same asset at a higher
density and uses that.
So on XHDPI tablets
like the Nexus 10,
that one bucket larger--
that one size larger icon
is actually XXHDPI or
480 dots per inch.
The important thing to note
here is that the tablet
itself, the screen itself,
is not XXHDPI.
It's simply that the framework
and the launcher will be
looking at XXHDPI.
It'll be looking for an
icon in that folder.
So basically, you want to
provide just the launcher icon
in 480 DPI and nothing else
because everything else will
just not be used.
So XHDPI for all your regular
assets, and then your launcher
icon should be in both
XHDPI and XXHPI.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
I believe this only holds
true for tablet.
So Nexus 7 included, but not for
handsets, is that right?
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
All right.
And I think that's really
all the slides we had.
So let's jump into-- let
me just turn off
the screenshare here.
Let's jump into the
discussion.
So to get started, I'd say we
should all just introduce
ourselves really quickly.
Like I said, I'm Roman,
and we have Adam here.
Do you guys want to just go
around table to introduce
yourselves, maybe starting
with Akhil.
AKHIL INDURTI: OK.
Hey, guys.
I'm a 17-year-old Android
developer
from Ashburn, Virgina.
I've only recently started.
I finished learning Java
extensively, and I'm actually
going to apply to the Google's
Computer Science Institute in
the summer.
So hopefully, I can see
you guys there.
I use Fireworks as my program
of choice for design.
And obviously, I like to use
Eclipse because it's easy to
work with for me.
OK, that's my introduction.
ROMAN NURIK: OK.
Do you want to move on to Ed?
ED LEA: Yup.
Hi, I'm Ed.
And I'm a designer
working mostly
Android, but iOS as well.
And I've worked for a company
called Qiip, and we're working
on bringing the Qiip hop up to
Holo standards at the moment,
so a bit Gingerbread.
ROMAN NURIK: Very cool.
All right, Linden, do
you want to go next?
LINDEN DARLING: G'day.
I'm Linden Darling.
I'm a professional Android
developer based in Australia.
I make my own apps, also provide
Android development to
banks and other companies
to make their apps.
I do a little bit of dabbling
in design and
multimedia as well.
ADAM KOCH: Cool, cool.
Linden, where are you
in Australia?
LINDEN DARLING: I'm
in Melbourne.
ADAM KOCH: OK.
I'm from Melbourne,
originally.
Hopefully, you've met our
counterparts in Sydney
[INAUDIBLE].
LINDEN DARLING: Yeah.
yeah, yeah.
I don't know why they're based
in Sydney to be honest.
ADAM KOCH: We used to have a
Melbourne office, but it's not
there anymore, actually.
ROMAN NURIK: Cool, all right.
And is it Ron or Ran?
RAN NACHMANY: It's Ran.
ROMAN NURIK: Ran, do you
want to go next?
RAN NACHMANY: I'm Ran.
I'm an Android developer
from Israel.
So we're covering, I think,
the whole world here.
We're only missing Nick
from the UK, and
then we' d have Europe.
Actually I'm a GDE, a software
expert, and I'm working a lot
here in the community and
providing professional
services to companies or
building community events,
talking in them, and so on.
ROMAN NURIK: Awesome.
Well, welcome to the Hangout.
And we have two other
participants, Oscar and--
I believe it's pronounced
"De-an-dre." I'm not sure.
But if you guys want to
introduce yourselves, feel
free, although your
video is muted.
If not, then we'll
just move on.
OK, and feel free to
join at any point.
Oh, is it "De-an-dre?" or am
I pronouncing that right?
DANDRE ALLISON: I'm Dandre.
ROMAN NURIK: Oh, Dandre.
Do you want to introduce
yourself?
DANDRE ALLISON: Sure.
I am a Android developer.
I started a little
over a year ago.
I'm in San Francisco.
I guess I started at the
interesting point where you
guys were switching to Holo and
3.0, and then Ice Cream
Sandwich came out, and
then Jelly Bean.
So it's been a pretty drastic
change since when I started
and how it is now.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, Android has
gone under somewhat of a
reimagining, I guess the core
visual image, and it's visual
identity has really just gone
under a complete renovation
since maybe, even
two years ago.
So, yeah, that's a great
time to join.
Welcome to Android.
And Oscar, we're assuming that
you're just a bit shy, or
don't want to join, or have
video meter or such.
But anyway, we'll just
get started.
Feel free to join when
you're ready.
God, I suck at working
Hangouts.
ADAM KOCH: No, no.
It's good, good.
ROMAN NURIK: OK.
So guys, do you want to just
start off with any sort of top
tips that you have or maybe
even like favorite apps or
anything like that?
The floor is really yours.
What types of things do you
want to talk about?
AKHIL INDURTI: I was wondering
if I could
show a design maybe?
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, sure.
Totally.
AKHIL INDURTI: And this
is my Chrome.
I actually showed Roman this.
I emailed him a while back.
And it's basically a
course-organizing app for
students that I'm currently
working on.
And it lets basically organize
all their courses, and
assignments, and schedules with
their teachers, and their
contacts with their teachers.
I have one question.
If you can see my contextual
action bar here, what color
should I make that?
ROMAN NURIK: Wow, of
all the questions.
So contextual action bars, I
mean, just using the default
color is generally fine.
In general, you really want
to just hint that it's a
different mode.
So really maybe a
darker version.
If you do want to change it,
then maybe a slightly darker
version of your core accent
color which seems to be brown.
I know the general palette is
kind of brown, like a dark
burnt orange and like
a tan paper.
So maybe something that's
somewhere along the spectrum,
maybe slightly darker.
But I think the big important
point here is that you just
want to visually indicate that
it's a different mode.
So as long as it's fairly
different from the standard
action bar, it should be OK.
If anybody else has thoughts
feel free to jump in.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah, i was just
going to say, I think it's
fine to leave it, to be honest,
unless you really want
to get that full theme-y
thing across, albeit
I think it's fine.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, and in
general, when we talk about
Holo, there's lots of different
guidelines that fold
under Holo, this
Holo umbrella.
One of those guidelines
is the visuals, right?
But I think for me the visuals
are less important, and what's
more important is the
interactions, right?
So having the check
box there, right?
Having the done button there is
far more important than the
specific color of
the action bar.
That is really up to you as a
designer to choose what looks
best to you But really, the core
things that you should be
leaving are the standard
expected interactions like
pressing the top left area,
which would be a check box to
close the action mode, having
the action overflow there in
case there are additional
actions.
So it's really, for me, more
about the interaction side of
things than the visual
side of things.
Although the visuals are
important, it's really just up
to you to make them look good.
AKHIL INDURTI: Yeah, and
one more question.
For the check boxes here, if
someone was to click on it, do
you think it's good for the
entire list item to go to the
bottom of the list, or should
they stay there?
ROMAN NURIK: The checkbox really
means that it's like a
completed task?
AKHIL INDURTI: Yeah.
ROMAN NURIK: In general,
I'd say--
and this is just
a general rule.
Do what people would expect.
In general, what users expect is
what they're used to, what
they're accustomed to.
And so if there is something on
the system, especially if
it comes with their device, if
there's a system app or a
platform app that does this
exact thing, then just mirror
what that does because that's
just what they're going to be
accustomed to.
In this case, I can't think of
anything where a check box
marks something as completed
that's built into the system.
So in this case, you don't
really have much of a default
to rely on.
One thing you could consider,
though, is when you interact
with something, if it's jumping
around, it's going to
be hard to continually
interact with it.
So let's say you wanted to
check it, mark it as
completed, and then do
something else to it.
If you mark it as checked and
then it jumps down, your
finger is no longer at the
relevant target, right?
So you basically have to
jump around there.
That's just another
minor point.
I think it's less important
than following conventions
because again, that's what
people are going to expect.
But I think in this case, having
it jump around too much
may be a negative thing.
Does anybody else have
comments on that?
ED LEA: Yeah.
If you did put it to the bottom
of the list, and the
bottom of the list is actually
off the bottom of the screen,
then you're probably going
to struggle to
find that moved item.
So maybe try and distinguish
it a bit more
than just being checked.
I know a lot of apps change the
color or maybe some kind
of strikethrough or something
if it's a done item.
That's quite a common pattern.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, and one of
our favorite apps, the Tasks
app by Team Tasks, they
do exactly that.
They just show an additional
strikethrough as an additional
visual indicator that something
is checked.
RAN NACHMANY: Actually,
I would go with a
swipe-to-dismiss instead
of a check box.
ROMAN NURIK: Definitely
another option.
Absolutely another option.
We talked about this, not last
week, but two weeks ago or
three weeks ago on
that episode.
Swipe to dismiss is definitely
another option.
Nick's very much in
favor of that.
RAN NACHMANY: You can see that
in task management, like
any.DO, they're doing it.
And I can't think of other apps,
but it's very natural to
the user to just get things
out of his way.
AKHIL INDURTI: I'm curious
on how you would go about
implementing the swipe
to dismiss, actually.
I may be going way
over my time.
So I'm probably done but--
RAN NACHMANY: Actually,
that's easy.
I think, Roman, it's your
library, right?
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, so--
I don't know if I have
keep pressing around.
God, these Hangouts are
very difficult.
So yeah, I wrote a library--
well, not a library, a gist on
GitHub that basically did swipe
to dismiss for you.
So for any list view or any
vertical linear layout, it
gives you that's swipe
automatically.
But one of the differences is
the item that you swipe to
dismiss actually
then goes away.
And so in this case, I don't
really know if you would want
the item to disappear so much
as you want to change its
visual state.
You may be able to use some of
the things from that library
in this app.
But I don't think necessarily
that swiping to hide the item
would work.
ADAM KOCH: One thing Nick
pointed out the other week was
a really nice pattern is to
swipe, and then have an Undo
button hiding underneath, and
then you tap that and it comes
back again.
Just another thing
to think about.
ROMAN NURIK: All right, Akhil,
maybe you want to show just
one more screen, then we'll
move on to other topics.
AKHIL INDURTI: Oh,
actually no.
I was done with my
screenshots.
ROMAN NURIK: All right,
well, overall, yeah
it was a great job.
Like you said, I did
see it before.
You sent me that email.
It's a great job overall.
There are just some
minor things.
But, yeah, following that
through and publishing it on
Google Play, let us know when
that happens, and we'll make
sure to take a look and see if
there's any sort of promotion
we can provide.
But yeah, it's a really great
start to the job there.
AKHIL INDURTI: All
right, thanks.
ROMAN NURIK: Anyone else want
to either show their work or
talk about--
and also one of the options,
if you want to rant about
something for like a full
minute, by all means.
There's plenty to rant
about, I'm sure.
But if you do want to rant
about it, that's
just another option.
But also if you have work to
show, if you want to get
comments from the rest of the
folks here, then that's
definitely another option.
Any takers?
LINDEN DARLING: Yeah, so I have
a couple things to show.
ROMAN NURIK: Let's see them.
LINDEN DARLING: Can
you hear me?
ROMAN NURIK: Yup.
LINDEN DARLING: Yeah,
yeah, cool.
OK.
So I'll be real quick.
Obviously, there's the Android
Assets Viewer, which I think
everyone is going to
find very useful.
Another thing is a little
library that I've been working
on that basically extends and
fixes up the setError
functionality I'll feature
in Android in a bit.
So I'll quickly show you that.
ROMAN NURIK:
Formidable-validation, that's
a cool name.
LINDEN DARLING: Yeah, yeah.
So it's providing easy
validation for forms as well
as making the feedback
consistent.
So you've got setError
working for any
TextView-derived class or view.
But it doesn't work for, say,
a spinner or a selector.
Basically, you can
add setError.
You can extend any view and make
it setError-able and then
use this validation manager.
And it will be set the error
on anything that
got errors on it.
So that's stemmed from me having
to provide feedback in
very complex forms
and Android apps.
ROMAN NURIK: So if you have even
like a check box or like,
for example, I accept the terms
and conditions, if you
don't check it, you can
have a an error
bubble show above that.
I'm guessing, right?
LINDEN DARLING: Yeah,
so that's like a
dependency sort of.
It's the way I've categorized or
named something like that.
For instance, here if you're
signing up to a newsletter,
you've clicked the "yeah,
I want to sign up to the
newsletter" check box.
That then makes the email
address fields necessary.
So if that wasn't checked, then
you wouldn't be getting
an error frame on that one.
So it's got a couple
validators.
Generally a lot of people are
going to be using the regular
expression validator, but you
can write your own ones and
add them in as well.
So, yeah, this is Open Source.
And it would be great if you
guys could have a look, and
anyone that's interested in
using it or adding to it or
extending it gets involved,
that would be sweet.
ROMAN NURIK: Cool.
And what was the Android
Assets Viewer?
I remember reading about
it a little bit.
But do you want to give a brief
overview and maybe show
some examples?
LINDEN DARLING: Yeah, let
me just share that one.
Tell me if you can see it.
ROMAN NURIK: Yep.
LINDEN DARLING: Is
that up now?
ROMAN NURIK: Mm-hm.
LINDEN DARLING: OK, so it's --
again, it stemmed from, I
suppose, pains that I've found
in different contracts working
quickly to make apps and
working with designers that are
generally new to Android.
So basically, the idea is you
want to provide an easy way to
show graphics and look at all
of the graphics across your
different size buckets, all
the drawable variants.
So this does that and
gives a little
bit of analysis feedback.
It's showing you whether your
sizes are right, whether
you've got odd pixels, or
whether you're going to have
half-pixels and stuff.
For instance, this
is the assets.
I've uploaded the assets from
formidable-validation, that
library I just showed you, and
you can see them here, that
it's showing different sizes.
So you've got your
LDPIs your MDPIs.
There's even the XXHDPI in
there, just to be super fresh.
And here, it's missing an
XXHDPI, but it's saying that
basically if you were to put
that in, the right size of it,
it's shown in green.
It's 96 by 96.
So it's just providing--
ROMAN NURIK: Does it look
at which assets
you currently have?
So if you have some random
assets that's like 40 by 40 in
MDPI, it will show you what the
equivalent is in XHDPI in
an empty slot if
it's not there?
LINDEN DARLING: Yeah, yeah.
That's exactly what it's
doing here, right?
So all of these are based
off MDPI at the moment.
I might add something to look
at sizing based on other
buckets if the MDPI
isn't there.
But you can see here that
the MDPI is 48 by 48.
It's suggesting that
the XHDPI--
well, it's saying that it's
not there, and it
should be 96 by 96.
You can see, here that TVDPI
is always going to have odd
pixels or half-pixels.
And so it's I guess a way of
when you're talking to
designers that are trying to
give you iOS graphics and
don't want to do any more work,
this is a great way to
bring them on board and
show them things.
ED LEA: How do you put those?
LINDEN DARLING: What was that?
Sorry?
ED LEA: How do you actually
put your assets into this?
LINDEN DARLING: Oh, yeah.
So you just upload either
an APK or a zip file.
If you're afraid that I'm going
to reverse-engineer your
APK, which I could do anyway
just getting it off the
market, you can just
zip you're res
folder and upload that.
So It's looking for a res
folder that's containing
drawable folders.
So you've got your
drawable LDPI--
no DPIs.
Well, whatever--
you might have your extra-large
whatever bucket is there.
It's going to show them all.
ROMAN NURIK: Awesome All right,
Linden, we're running a
little low on time, but
what's the fastest--
LINDEN DARLING: One
last quick thing.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, sure.
LINDEN DARLING: One
last quick thing--
the Device Viewer.
So this is something I added
just recently, and it lets you
view this stuff on real devices,
scaled as though it's
on that device.
So it gives you a real quick
glimpse as to how things are
going to scale and how those
graphics and different buckets
are going to look on different
devices at their original
smaller size.
In this case, it's a 9-patch
with scale, and you can get it
just for what it would look
like at its smallest size.
ROMAN NURIK: And the most
important thing, Linden, how
do you get to this
awesome tool?
LINDEN DARLING: Yeah, so it's
at celebellum.net--
which is like cerebellum
if you hold your
tongue and say it--
slash androidassetsviewer.
So I'll just show you there.
ADAM KOCH: We can post a
link up in the Google+
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, we'll
definitely post a link
afterwards.
LINDEN DARLING: Yeah, yeah.
ROMAN NURIK: OK.
Let's move on, though,
since we're running a
little low on time.
I just want to get one last
thing from everybody
who wants to answer.
What would you like to see in
a future episode of Android
Design in Action?
What specific topics would
you like us to cover?
And let's it, I guess,
from Akhil.
AKHIL INDURTI: Crouton
versus Toasts.
ROMAN NURIK: Crouton
AKHIL INDURTI: I'm wondering.
ROMAN NURIK: OK.
AKHIL INDURTI: It's a new
library, and I was just
wondering who's out there
using Crouton right now.
ROMAN NURIK: OK, yeah.
It's an awesome library.
It's definitely interesting to
provide a different and more
contextual Toast almost.
Definitely a good topic, we'll
keep that in mind.
Dandre, any thoughts?
DANDRE ALLISON: I'll
pass for now.
ROMAN NURIK: OK.
All right, Ed or Linden?
ED LEA: Yeah, I've got
a couple of requests.
And I guess one of them is the
production process from
graphics to developer and how
do you manage that process?
Do you design MDPI and then just
email it over graphics,
or do you share some repo--
just the whole production
process would be quite good.
I guess a little bit on fonts
and thoughts on including more
than just the bold and regular,
and whether that's a
good idea to do or not.
And then tablet apps, a lot of
developers have got mobile
apps out there, which could
work on a Nexus 7.
How much effort should be put
in to releasing for a tablet
versus making people wait for
the app and releasing a custom
type of app?
ROMAN NURIK: Totally.
And we did have an episode
recently on responsive design,
but we're definitely going to do
more on tablet design since
it is a nuanced area in
designing for mobile since
it's like semi-mobile, but
definitely something that
we're going to continue
to talk about.
And those other suggestions
we're great.
We're definitely going to
looking into that as well.
Linden and Ran, any thoughts on
things we should cover for
future episodes?
LINDEN DARLING: I mean, the
stuff that Nick and Marie did
at some conference in Germany,
I saw a video for that where
they did a redesign on the fly
and showed the thoughts that
would go in the plan, and
that's really useful and
interesting.
I think something like that
could be good to do again.
ROMAN NURIK: Definitely.
LINDEN DARLING: You do it
with obviously lots
of different apps.
You guys started doing that with
your looking at apps at
the moment as well.
But I think having the design
tools out there and showing
how people can do it
quickly as well.
And also tackling the big
problem of making an app look
good on Honeycomb Plus, but as
well as old Gingerbread 2.2,
without, say, using--
just going for a pure Holo
theme and trying to
pull that all back.
This is just the main problem.
I know you guys are pushing
for the newest
style all the time.
But the reality is that apps out
there and companies want
to target as much of the market
as they can, and stuff
just doesn't look that great.
Not everything--
even Holo, everywhere doesn't
bring everything back, and so
if there's any tricks or talking
about some of the
issues there.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah, so like maybe
potentially an episode
dedicated at backward
compatibility and designing
for earlier devices.
That makes a lot of sense.
Since that is a very pragmatic
view of the current landscape,
is most devices are below
Android 3.0, so definitely
something we should look at.
OK, and Ran do you have
any thoughts on
what we should include?
RAN NACHMANY: Thoughts, and
a request, actually.
I started working
on a project.
It will be basically a
car-mounted tablet.
It will replace the
entertainment system.
And will also talk with some
chip inside the vehicle that
talks with other vehicles,
other cars, to provide
collaborative safety.
I don't know if you guys have
heard of that standard.
It's called 11P.
But never mind.
We're not going to look
at that today.
The idea is that it's a 7-inch
tablet that is going to be
used-- the application
is going to be used
dedicatedly in a car.
It needs to be operated by a
driver or the passenger, but
also by the driver.
So there needs to
be very little
interaction with the user.
And obviously, action bar
cannot fit there.
It's too small, things
like that.
So right now, we're banging
our head against the wall
trying to figure out what will
be the best way or approach to
show a map, some very
necessary available
information, and that's it, and
still be very responsive
and intuitive to the
user if he wants
to go to other screens.
And you've done some amazing job
with the design guide, but
it's all focused for mobile
phones, and mobile usage, and
that stuff.
And actually, Android is going
to other areas and not just
handsets, tablets but also--
[FUZZY AUDIO].
ROMAN NURIK: So basically
exploring how to design for
alternative or auxiliary
use cases, right?
RAN NACHMANY: Exactly.
ROMAN NURIK: So outside of the
standard holding a phone in
your hand or holding a tablet
in your two hands.
Yeah, definitely something
we can look at.
We'd probably need to see a few
example devices, right?
A few example use cases.
But definitely we can imagine
what is the next step,
designing for the next step or
the evolution of Android
devices in different areas
and different use case.
ADAM KOCH: And there are some
apps that need to do something
like that anyway.
Like navigation apps, for
example, that have catered to
that use case.
ROMAN NURIK: Totally.
OK, so we're super low on time,
but we just want to run
through a few last slides.
We have a little bit more
information to share.
So bear with us for
just a second.
So let's just quickly
run through news.
And there isn't too much news.
Oh, actually the most important
bit of news here is
that a uistencils.com has
recently released an Android
tablet stencil kit.
And this is like a physical
metal piece of kit, I guess,
that you plop down on some
paper, you fill in the blanks,
and you get your standard
iconography.
You get your standard . widgets,
things like that.
So if you're looking to sketch
on real paper with real pens
and pencils, then try
to get this kit.
We actually do have
an example here.
And you're not going to
be able to see it.
I'll show it after.
But the really cool thing
is that we have
a few to give away.
So we're going to be giving
away about 10.
So the way in which we're going
to do this is that we're
going to ask the greater
community to take a few
screens from one of their
favorite apps, or even their
own app, redesign it using some
of the Holo elements that
you've see on this show, and
then post it to Google+
publicly by the end
of the week.
And when you do post, make sure
to use the hashtags ADIA
and AndroidDesign so
we can see them.
So the first or maybe the best
10-- we don't really know yet.
We'll try to send out some
of these stencils.
And these stencils, I think they
retail for like $27 on
uistencil.com.
So if you want to just get them
and not wait for us to
look at your stuff, then you
go to uistencils.com
and get your copy.
And we'll post details about
this giveaway at some point on
Google+ as well, probably
right after this show.
Also, I did two posts
very recently.
First on wizard design, like
designing a wizard, in this
case, one the lets you order a
sandwich, very, oddly enough.
But it's got all sorts of things
like dependencies, like
dependent sections and
things like that.
So if you're designing wizards,
check out that post.
And then lastly, cheat sheets.
There's another post I did.
Basically, in the action bar, as
many of you know, when you
long-press an icon in the
action bar, it shows you
little toast, a little tool
tip that pops up and
says what that does.
This is really useful outside
of just the action bar.
So if throughout your UI you
have icon-only UI elements,
you'll want to use something
like this to give the user an
extra bit of confidence that
what they're about to press
does what they think.
So this is especially important
in cases where your
iconography may not make
perfect sense.
So there's a library--
I guess another GitHub gist that
shows you how you could
do this, and that's the
apps I have here.
So I think that's all the
slides we have today.
Thanks again for
joining, guys.
We're hoping to do a
few more of these
Hangouts in the future.
For the next few weeks, we'll
probably go back to our
regularly scheduled Android
Design in Action, where we
will be doing redesigns.
But look for other invitations
to join another Hangout
sometime in the next, say, few
weeks or next two months.
So thanks for joining everybody,
and I guess we'll
see you next week.
Thanks, guys.